the last in the twenty joe subury that
uh the points i can think of
is uh miggy it means opposite uh
opposite side
mighty nagari geishi ski
and um and then we normally put
uh 19 and 20 together and it's
just something that we do it's uh it's
not really
a suburbia it's starting to get more
like a feeling of a carter but
it can introduce you then into what it
should feel like
to flow the weakness is
when we start to flow and enjoy it we
miss out certain points like
i just spoken about in the number 19
and that is we miss out the power that
the block
requires okay so we end up with two
strikes but
uh no block in the middle and the block
is important
miggy nagari guys his skin
earlier i was telling you about this
pushing
with the left you need a direction
so push it to the left like if it was a
clock
this is at 12 two o'clock ten o'clock
eleven one two so
push it to two o'clock but your hips
don't go
that way because you're gonna go that
way
so this would be a waste of going one
way to go the other
don't go backwards to go forwards so my
my hips come forwards even though my
hands go here
but in meginagardi i'm going the other
side
so this time i push it
to the opposite i push it this way
don't push it forwards or else it'll
cramp up on your wrist don't make it a
big
sweep because then it's taking you that
way
you're going to strike showman but
you're going to
take it across so
this can go at 10 o'clock towards 11
o'clock
so build it up
with the steps
10 o'clock the left hand
the right hand stays in front of you
get to this point i know i've stepped
forward
but this is all a part of building up
the timing
edge edge
h h
h
now i'm going to put it together so by
timing so my foot and joe
end together
okay
this goes
up ah
this goes out this goes
up
this goes out
this goes up
up but you must have this one doing
something
then add this one
don't start this and then push that up
whereas this one dies
has no energy to it so the feeling is
push up
push
you see you start putting all the timing
together
please watch the feet
as in number nine joseph early
with shiro ski where we go to the end of
the joe
you need to find this feeling back from
then
to now
and we block
step back load
make sure the block again with in the
bari movement i said don't start
striking the head then stepping back
whereas you'll find that you can't
strike the head you strike first
then you step back strike first
then step back this is the same
covering the head no good here covering
the head
back foot opens step back
load
oh
check all the points from the past is it
past your body
is it too short
check each video of yourself you see
these faults
and weaknesses note them
keep correcting yourself and never do
enough basics
another weakness
people do this
you can see my head is sticking out
either side so this
left side isn't being protected must be
the fullness of the head that's covered
now we can put together 19 and 20.
ski
okay
it gives you the carter feeling
the cartridge understanding carter
feeling
the key honking
so
i hope you've enjoyed the trendy joe
suberi
there's never enough time and effort you
can put into them
you will always uh find weaknesses
that you've perhaps not found yet
or things that need polishing more i
hope
these uh training that i've explained in
detail
will help you grow and find a smoother
path
through our senses aikido these are all
to develop your tai jitsu your body
movements
and i hope that my explanations have
shown you that
uh many times you get the same feeling
from one
uh jose berry to another
and how they're all really interlinked
and once you become
at ease with them and do them correctly
you will
advance swiftly i'm sure thanks for your
time
tomorrow